hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast engaging through
enrichment how the animal enrichment
committee works to combat compassion
fatigue and it's presented by Jennifer
Jones an animal enrichment coordinator
lead animal technician at University of
Michigan Medical School I'm Suzy Valdez
elaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab rich is a
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen type the questions into
the drop down box that appear on the
screen and I'll answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on that help desk button located upon to
the promotional board at the bottom
center of your screen or use that ask a
question box this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits click on the
accreditation button located on the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain those credits please join me now
in welcoming our presenter Jennifer
Jones I will now turn the presentation
over to her welcome Jennifer
thank you as Suzy said my name is Jenny
Jo I won at the University of Michigan I
am very excited to talk to you today
about how we use our animal enrichment
program to help combat compassion
fatigue I am will admit that I am an
animal person not a people person I
think many of you can relate that's how
we ended up in this field in the first
place but amusingly I have spent most of
my time in the last year or so talking
about people how to communicate with
them and how to better improve the
environment in the workplace and as
strange as it is for me to be focused on
people I think that we will find that it
is imperative that we give the same
level of care to our human issues as we
do to our animal concern
today I'm going to do a brief overview
of compassion fatigue in the animal
sciences including our initial efforts
within our department at education and
mitigation I will jump to a description
of our animal enrichment committee its
current structure and mission I think it
is really important to understand what a
strong foundation this committee has and
how that helps it excel in areas even
outside of providing animal enrichment
I will then jump to our new directions
to address compassion T we are always
looking for ways to improve our efforts
and hopefully you'll see some of the
improvements we've made as we've
continued to evaluate our program
so compassion fatigue can be described
as basically a chronic state of stress
that people who are in a caregiving
situation sign and closed them it is
often called secondary trauma so by
dealing with either people or animals in
distress you find yourself in a
perpetual state of stress and tension
here you can see the common symptom and
they range from relatively mild to very
severe that depends on how it affects
you so obviously this can interfere with
both your everyday life at home and at
work
so looking at in the recent years
there's been an increased awareness of
how compassion fatigue can impact all of
us that are involved in laboratory
animal science you can see pictured here
there's an informational pamphlet from
ALS describing the cost of caring and
recently on one of their last Pro covers
they featured an article about how your
well-being matters and how institutions
can mitigate compassion fatigue
they are also hosting a compassion
fatigue related webinar in February
so for those of us in the animal
sciences it might be hard for us to
receive outside support from what we
would consider our normal support group
they have family or friends it can be
harder for us than someone in a more
traditional caring field or they first
recognized issues such as compassion
fatigue the nurses can tease and first
other first responders it's easy for
people outside of those fields to
recognize the value of their work
I think this would look familiar to a
lot of us as it says oh I could never do
your job I love animals too much I think
many of us have been tempted to reply
something along the lines of I think you
meant to say thank you for your service
I have had many many versions of this
interaction I've referred to it as the
sad head-tilt which since you can't see
me on the webcam I can't demonstrate but
you say what you do for a living and you
get the all really and I have
experienced this even when dealing with
medical professionals the people that
you would think have a basis of
scientific knowledge and an
understanding of what we do
so if you think about it why do people
have trouble providing support for a
family member or friend who's dealing
with issues in our job some of it is our
field has a lack of transparency which
leads to a lack of understanding of what
we do and why it's important and if you
think about it farther someone who's
experiencing compassion fatigue so
basically they're in a moment where
they're stressed by what they do or sad
about it they're not in a good position
to educate that family member or friends
about what we do and why it matters so
since we can't get support from those
traditional places the workplace can
step up to fill that gap and provide
from these essential services so in
addition to basically being what I think
is the right thing to do there are
potential benefits to the workplace for
providing support for employees
hopefully you could see a reduction in
turnover people are less fatigued
there'd be more likely to stay an
increase in morale and motivation you
might say improvements in efficiency
general demeanor also an increased
ability to handle the day-to-day
stressors at work appropriately I think
this is a big one when people are
experiencing compassion fatigue they are
at such a heightened state of stress
that something small and simple that
they might have been able to be a with
normally I can be especially educating
and this can lead to increased friction
between coworkers
something simple that you might consider
petty that could have been easily works
or moved past before suddenly becomes a
much bigger deal it can also be seen
between staff and researchers so you
have an animal care technician and they
come upon a situation where maybe a lab
didn't do something following the
correct SOP typically a minor issue take
it to a supervisor and sometimes the
result of having these employees who are
so stressed or fatigued and is it become
a big situation that you have an
employee yelling at a researcher and
this is an impact to your customer
service as well so hopefully if the
workplace steps up and helps employees
find different ways to deal with us you
can have smooth relationships between
co-workers and customers
so our department after recognizing that
compassion fatigue was a big basically a
mental health crisis in our field what
do we do first so a team at the
university reached out to the
professional counselors that were
available through our University's
Employee Assistance Program so they
reached out to them and they discuss
some of the unique challenges that we
face in our field they made sure that
these counselors were able to listen and
then provide support appropriately to
people you don't want to be in the
situation where you deal with a
counselor who would make you feel more
guilty about what you do and in some
cases counselors themselves have
experienced a secondary trauma if they
are not prepared for the types of
situations they might be hearing about
so by addressing this first we knew that
we were in a good place with our
professional counselors they helped I
have set up educational seminars for the
entirety of the department so they held
several different large seminars
featuring talks from both our peers and
these professional counselors
so it discussed the different
complications people might see and
compassion fatigue and having the
counselor also helped lens with
legitimacy to these seminars which helps
people take it more seriously since that
time we have added information into all
of our training programs for our animal
handlers
so both husbandry and lab staff both
receive information to specific much
like how we explain to people that
animal allergies are common when working
with animals we now also explain about
compassion fatigue and its symptoms and
the resources that are available for
people should they choose it
this was a very important first step so
now we've recognized that this exists
and that it is completely normal because
I know a lot of people have been in the
field a long time will know that it
wasn't something we used to talk about
so for some people just having a name
for it being able to acknowledge it and
understand that you are not alone was
enough to help them on their own address
these issues and move on and feel better
those very important steps just make
sure everyone knows what it is and then
we continue to find differently at work
to help them deal with them
real quick to the animal enrichment
committee which is my happy place in its
simplest form it is a committee that we
that exists to help maintain evaluate
and refine our animal enrichment program
and this is the program across our whole
campus
we are constantly striving for
improvement we'd never treat our program
as if it's finished
this committee was founded at least 10
years ago by a single husbandry
technician who saw room for change in
recent years we've all seen a big shift
and not only how enrichment is viewed
but what is required so in that time as
these things have changed this committee
has been able to lead to big changes
being implemented in our whole program
so the committee meets monthly where we
cover new ideas as well as evaluate how
our current program is doing the
structure of our committee I think is
part of what gives it a lot of its
strength so we are open to everyone in
the department as you can see we have
representatives from our best staff our
management training course faculty vets
our husbandry staff and of course myself
our animal enrichment coordinator
we have discovered it is valuable to
have people from all these different
sections not only because you gained a
greater perspective we also have found
that we can make more efficient and
better decisions regarding enrichment
when you have all the people in one
space so you have someone who brings an
idea you can look to management and see
if it would be financially possible you
have faculty veterinarians there to talk
about safety and other animal welfare
concerns and then you have your health
and your staff to tell you if it's
feasible to add that in to their
everyday care of the animals
we are working to include more lab staff
in our program
right now we have a lot of involvement
from our non-human primates labs which
makes sense as that's a more dynamic
part of our program we have some of our
Pig labs who have reached out to let us
know that basically there's stuff that
we don't have time for our husbandry
technicians to do such as sit with the
pig while it plays in the kiddie pool
but they have undergrads that they would
be willing to volunteer for that test
and we also have a volunteer that came
to us from a mouse lab but wanted to be
more connected with the other animals
that we had and she helps build extra
enrichment and if you watch my colleague
Sarah's presentation on our rabbit
social housing program you will
understand that we need a lot of
additional enrichment to keep those
socially housed rabbits happy
so the animal enrichment committee was
of course not designed with compassion
fatigue in mind but if you look at the
structure and how it works you can see
that it is a natural fit to help connect
compassion fatigue the committee
provides the place for technicians and
anyone from the department have their
ideas and concerns birds and this in and
of itself can be a big help it gives our
staff a feeling of control
and they benefit from having a
structured process every idea is brought
to the committee in the same way we
provide feedback on if we'd be able to
do it if not why the idea is rejected
what changes we could possibly make to
make it work this leaves people feeling
more respected and then over the years
we've managed to make quite a few
improvements that has improved the
welfare of our animals
in addition the animal enrichment
committee was interested in becoming
more involved in engaging our employees
because we've discovered that typically
the employees who want to participate in
the animal enrichment committee are
those who are very passionate and
excited about enriching the lives of
their animals and they are also more
susceptible to compassion fatigue so we
want to see these people staying with us
and being productive members of our team
so we started with some simple efforts
to expand our community basically we
recognized that being involved in the
committee was beneficial to people so
how do we expand those to reach more
staff within our department
so we started looking at these efforts
to increase involvement
they're hoping we would find and
untapped resources staff that might be
eager to volunteer some extra time to
help us in Richmond and we want to
spread those positive benefits as many
people as possible one of our very first
projects was a holiday ornaments sale
our vet techs actually came up with the
idea and got the supplies to make those
adorable mouths
candy cane covers that you can see in
the picture we got those along with a
few other holiday themed Mouse things
and sold them to people within the
department the proceeds of which went to
purchasing special enrichment items that
we were not in our budget so we bought a
new puzzle feeder for non-human primates
this ended up being very popular with
our office staff and we partially
surmised as they might just be less
tired of looking at me but they were
very excited to have a little mouse
trinket and also to know that some other
animal is going to get something fun
because of it
this was a learning experience and our
technicians were actually less than Susy
astok about it
we had some pushback on myself that it
was inappropriate basically to be
raising money to purchase things that
they felt that we should be able to
purchase through our normal program so
going forward if we were ever to do
something similar we've already picked
out several outside institutions that
also benefit animals and research that
we feel that people might be more
excited about donating to such as homes
for Heroes or monkey island where they
take retired laboratory primates our
next step was we instituted a toilet
paper tube recycling program so the
first part of that was sending out the
adhesive from the tubes to make sure it
was safe for our animals then we posted
signs in all of our areas alerting lab
staff that we could take collection of
toilet paper tubes and paper towel tubes
we autoclave them and then give them to
the animals this was our easiest and
best way to connect with our lab staff
which they can be harder to loop in on
some of our efforts they were very
excited one to be able to contribute and
then to they could see the results very
easily because I walked in their room
and could see my with living inside
their little toilet paper tubes we
expanded the program to also include
plastic milk or water drugs which we
give frequently to our pigs who love to
destroy them with great enthusiasm
to further expand our community
engagement we started holding
opportunities for socialization and
training with our large animal we had a
large cat study involving vaccines and
all of those cats were going to be up
for adoption
so we allowed technicians to sign up in
groups of two to come sit with them and
provide a little additional basically
love and this allowed several benefits
for our technicians one they got to
spend some time hopefully with a person
they enjoyed since they signed up with
them and they got some extra cat cuddles
in and knew that these cats we're going
to go live their life out after being
adopted we also have a group of dogs
right now that are preparing for
adoption so they have a similar
socialization and play our four
technicians can join in and help wrangle
them in their play area we've expanded
the training program we have a great
technician who's pictured there Kayla
who I'm pretty impressed and get all the
beagles to sit at one
and so she's been working on basic
commands and obedience again to assist
them when they're adopted out we have
expanded it to include blocks on leash
through the vivarium this has had the
fun added benefit of basically the dogs
bring joy wherever they go who doesn't
want to run into a puppy in the hallway
we also had signs mades alerting
research staff that they would see the
dogs out and about and the purpose of it
and what to do and they saw them so
we've even extended that fun benefit of
people that might not run into them
still know that they're out and about
and having these fun walks and recently
we started doing office visits so those
of us with offices in the vivarium and
find out a dog for an hour at a time the
dog can come to the office and it has
special soft beds and other toys that
they can't have normally in their
kennels we've already seen great benefit
our shyest dog almost immediately came
out of her shell when she got some
quality alone time and this has been a
great way not only to enrich the dog but
also the people in their offices and to
highlight that we have these amazing
dogs that would be available for
adoption
another way we thought to expand was to
create an event that we could sponsor
for Tech Week which is currently going
on right now so we sponsored in our
first year want to say 2015 a mineral
painting competition as you can see it
was an excellent team-building activity
we got some unexpected artistic
challenge least I was fairly impressed
the murals are all pieces on sheets and
they're machine washable so we rotate
them through our large animal room to
provide additional visual enrichment
there are also a few that were just kind
of weird so it's not entirely unexpected
my favorite anecdote so it does kind of
hurt my feelings a bit is one of our
large animal users saw these and was
like well what's that for it I explained
that this is a way to just provide a
change of scenery and additional visual
stimulation she thought on it for a
moment and then said oh well why
wouldn't we just give them something
they might actually want to see
obviously she was not impressed with our
artistic talents but it got her to think
about what she could provide for her
animals in a different way and that lab
actually purchased large details with
photographs of pasture scenes and sheep
and they place those on the walls with
their recovery room so there she
benefited from this project in a way
that we couldn't even have imagined
right now we are continuing the
tradition these are a few pictures from
the submissions from our tech week and
yatta making contest this year the
voting is going on as I speak and we
will count a winner tomorrow they will
win the right to pie a supervisor in the
face we will see how that goes it has so
far been a fun positive team-building
experience and then our non-human
primates and pigs will get to completely
destroy the pinata and pursue per vision
next week
so since those Tech Week events and Sur
events such as the socialization little
parties were so successful for like well
how do we expand this even farther we
had reached quite a few people but we
thought we could reach more and make it
more consistent at this point the tech
week is once a year and then some of the
other projects were just sort of when we
had different resources available so we
thought about it we set the goals of
wanting to create these events that
would be relaxing inclusive and to build
that sense of community we wanted as
many of our texts and other staff to be
involved and then since we were the
animal enrichment committee we wanted to
make usable items that can actually be
integrated into our regular enrichment
program
so the obstacle to accomplices you'll be
very familiar with biggest are time and
money obviously it takes time for staff
to participate in any of them time for
the staff to them take the enrichment
items and give them to the animals and
then money for materials the harder to
pin down obstacle is we want people to
understand and appreciate the impact of
the work so obviously we're glad that
people have fun and can goof around and
make a pinata but we want that
connection to the animal that receives
it so that they can recognize that
they're benefiting the animals in
addition to having a good time
overcome these obstacles we work to
design activities that were relatively
inexpensive could be completed in a
short amount of time and for the most
part can be completed in the individual
break rooms across our different
buildings we have a large campus we have
animals in over 10 different buildings
and so the time it takes to bring the
staff together is a much larger time
commitment then we typically would get
support for
so if they can do it in their own
building then we can do like we did with
the pinata contest
well the floating pole actually goes
live to everyone in the department so
everyone can still see what everyone
else did
so to give you an idea of inexpensive
activities for the mural painting
contest all we had to purchase were the
bedsheets for each team and all of our
paint was donated and then for the
pinata contest it was probably less than
$60 for the supplies that we purchase
and this is going to be so that over 120
different people can participate in this
event
so another way to overcome some of those
obstacles was we were like well why
don't we schedule out and plan farther
in advance so we created what your thing
is a mock-up of the first calendar we
kind of sketched out and as you can see
we have to be flexible
since originally we're going to save
pinatas for the spring time and they've
got moved to our tech week event
so by planning things out it can assist
in planning staff participation which
can help get support for management for
that time because you can give them an
idea of this time I want to bring
everyone together it will be longer but
this other one they can do in their
break room in increments of 15 minutes
which it really helps to have that
manager button ahead of time also when
you're planning it out having that
consistency of scheduling and prove the
usefulness of items that are created
since we actually want to use them in
our program we can plan ahead in
October's I know we're going to do
pumpkin how many animals do we have that
can receive them in what way do they
need to receive them do they have to be
supervised and you can have it all
planned out ahead of time so you don't
end up with pumpkins rotting before they
can get used another obstacles that we
still struggle at times to overcome is
there can be difficulty finding fun
things that we can do for all species we
have many many more mice then we have
other animals so most of our technicians
work primarily with mice a lot of the
fun ideas that we come up with our
centers around our larger species so we
are still working on how to come up with
ideas for all the different species
here is an example of a very successful
event this is our pumpkin carving
contest from last year we opened it up
to anyone in the department so I brought
pumpkin through all the husbandry teams
our vet packs all the way to our office
even though they looked very startled
when I arrived to the pumpkin our room
health around scheme our trainers and
actually our vet residents ended up
carving the winning pumpkin so everyone
carved pumpkins and then they were given
two species all away from rabbits up to
our non-human thymus
so that last obstacle of helping people
realize the benefit and impact of the
enrichment that they've created we focus
on communication and how can we
highlight how we use those items that
they made one of the ways that we do
this is by highlighting it at our all
staff meeting one of the few times that
we're all gathered together sometimes
this is as passive as we started
including fun pictures taken by our
communications person as I was cream
flavor before and in-between
presentations I had this fear the animal
enrichment committee created a thank you
card which is personally one of my
favorites a lot of us have worked with
the animals for a long time and we've
never had a picture
I had to take to have and so this is a
way that we get that positive you get a
smiling pig and a happy looking sheep
and you get to see the dogs enjoying all
the stuff that we do for them we still
struggle with how best to loop people in
so that they really feel that impact but
we're at a point where obviously you
can't have 88 technicians watching one
Pig destroy what and pumpkin so we're
still working on that
to continue on communication it can be
really easy to lose sense of the bigger
picture when you're changing cages every
day or cleaning cages so we strive to
highlight how research benefits both
animals and people out in our monthly
newsletter that goes out to our
department staff and then also
researchers as well anyone in our animal
care and youth program they highlight a
different research project at the
University and how it is benefiting
people in the real world
we also host lunch-and-learn events or
brown-bag lunches we're primarily
technicians can come and listen to our
researchers talk about their current
projects it has been a really fun way to
connect say those mice that you've been
taking care of for a year and suddenly
you know the bigger picture of what
they're a part of
also work really hard to encourage
continuing education
at least in our program a lot of our
technicians are very well educated and
Cajun cages and routine husbandry can be
fairly monotonous so we encourage
participation in a lab there's two
posters that are examples of the money
that we've taken to a less in recent
years we host webinars a technician
journal club keep people engaged in the
science and understanding and yeah
giving them something a little more
interesting to focus on
we are so fortunate to have the
refinement and enrichment advancements
laboratory here at the University I
stole this description from their
website it is founded by some of our
faculty that it brings together those
faculty does along with different
researchers our vet techs Humphrey techs
and residents all in the spirit of
finding ways to improve the welfare of
our animals and backing it up with the
science as anyone who has worked to
change enrichment or change even basic
husbandry care such as bedding or
nesting material for rodents you know
that you get a lot of pushback from
researchers so having this lab on campus
is a great way to be like oh we
understand your concerns and here's the
study that we did to show that our
technicians could still find sick or
dead mice even with a significant amount
of nesting material this group also
hosts training seminars which have
taught our staff different aspects of
the process so they've learned about
study design doing their own statistics
quality scientific writing and this has
been a great way to tap all those people
that maybe have noticed a problem have
had an idea but didn't know how to turn
it into something so we've had them turn
out things that have turned into a last
posters also projects that have gone all
the way to being full scientific papers
here are I know it's time
it's just some of the project could have
come out of having the real group on
campus so just to highlight a couple one
is which nest is best and they looked at
improving the survival of transgenic
rabbit kits by improving their nesting
they tested a couple different kinds and
they were able to make substantial
increase in the survival rate was
something that was essentially a pretty
straightforward project they've also
developed different behavioral ISA
Grahams one they used as a health
assessment in our feline vaccine studies
and they actually found that they could
pick up on behavioral changes before the
cats showed any clinical signs of
illness I just think these are example
of how when you keep passionate people
engaged they can come up with some
really quality projects
animal enrichment committee was
fortunate to be able to partner with MS
mer the Michigan Society for medical
research to host to enrichment
symposiums in 2016 and 2017 these
symposiums were led by our committee
which allowed people to take ownership
over all the different parts of the
symposium we contacted vendors went
through and found speakers of interest
and contacts and reached out to them
designed the schedule for the day made a
call-out for posters so again you get
this huge sense of ownership and pride
in what you're doing and the overall
outcome is also a day filled with
excellent presentations on the science
of enrichment which we also include as
many of our own technicians in attending
as we can
I just can't fit enough good things
about this event it's something that we
will be hosting again in April
so going back to some of the more
classic ways that people have addressed
compassion fatigue and that we've tried
at the university as well one of the
first things we tried was setting up a
peer support group and like it sounds it
was entirely pure led with no
professional the first efforts produce
some interesting results there was a lot
of interest from the staff which I feel
like shows that there was a need for it
but they were kind of difficult to
manage you had a mix of people some of
these are technicians who have worked in
the field for ten years and no one has
ever asked them for these stories or
allowed them to share them in an
environment where they felt safe which
led to it big and powerful but also very
emotional this led to a bit of a
reputation that some of these meetings
were a bit depressing
so in these meeting I've said it was a
learning curve
separating out compassion fatigue and
the importance of having a meeting to
share those feelings versus burnout in
general with a difficult challenge at
first when you open up the floor and let
people get stuff out it can be hard to
separate between productive sharing and
what becomes just negative venting at
the time we first started during the
peer support group there were only four
technicians they thought was that if you
included people from different levels in
the department that you might end up
with people I feel like uncomfortable or
that they were unable to share
we're going forward
decided that we needed a few different
ways to help separate ourselves a bit
from what was considered these sort of
meetings that when one person was asked
that they wanted to attend they said
well no because I don't feel like crying
today so we want to sort of revamp the
image a bit
brings us to our new compassion fatigue
committee so this slide is from our
recent January meeting and it highlights
the new goals for 2018
so now instead of just being open to
technicians this is open to all staff
within the department so it is still
it's safe space where people can share
at but we've taken some steps to
structure it a little bit and encourage
people to first share positive
experiences and we're still working to
make sure that we can have open honest
conversations without falling into too
much talk of burnout
our first meeting this year we held that
informational meeting and then we
followed it up with an enrichment event
so we animal enrichment committee set us
up with supplies to wrap presents for
all the different species so it led with
a nice positive hands-on event which
helps people feel comfortable and we
still provided time at that point to
share it was a great way to kick off the
new year
one of the most common things that you
will hear and talking about compassion
fatigue is self-care and the importance
of it I can't really agree with it more
I love the quotes that talk about how
you need to take care of yourself
because you want to give the best
everyone in your life this illustration
shows a lot of a common self-care tips
but again it's a very personal thing I
always include this monkey is taking a
bath because that's one of the first
things on our list is take a quiet
bubble bath and while some people might
find that relaxing I have a co-worker
who thinks if that just sounds like
absolute worst so I would recommend
doing it to a large group of people it's
important to emphasize that it is
specific to the person
you want to build your resilience by
doing these good signals for yourself
but we did run into a lot of pushback
primarily you have people come to work
all day and care for animals and they go
home and have to care for their families
so you suggest will take time and read a
book you enjoy which they were fun at
what point in time you think may you
know two kids are going to let that
happen
so we wanted to kind of look at how we
could help people achieve a little
self-care maybe not at home so again
from our January meeting we looked at
setting up small manageable goals that
could perhaps be accomplished even at
work and then by having them as a group
goal you find that you have a little bit
of accountability so our January goal
was to add in one source of positive
media per workday and we focus on
podcast since a lot of our technicians
have their earphones them all day and
listened to a variety of podcast this is
something that I've added my own review
and it can be quite up listening to take
a break from true-crime podcast which
while interesting can be a little
depressing and by setting these goals
together it also allows us to follow up
on them in the next meeting and we've
also set up a shared Facebook group and
we're hoping that different types of
people will benefit from having this
increased structure around healthcare
goals
one of the last ways to help feel as
compassion fatigue or Memorial events I
think these can be a very important part
of the grieving process the ones
pictured here were from our 2016 and
2017 science of enrichment symposiums so
we simply invited people fill out a card
and then assembled them into a memorial
wall in the first symposium we were a
little bit worried about participation
because you never know how people will
feel about sharing and but it was
incredibly moving to see how quickly
people filled out their cards we had
comments from veterinarians who had been
working in the field for 20 or 30 years
that they still had a specific memory
from vet school that they wanted that
they were excited to share and some
people just wrote the name of an animal
the following year we did a similar
memorial wall and we also gave out a
seed paper in the shape of hearts so
that people could take a little
something home and plant a small
memorial garden in there at their house
our goal is to expand this into a much
larger event at our University we'd like
to host a celebration event to
yeah share the positive benefits of
research to have a moment to respect and
appreciate the animal lives that we've
used obviously you run into transparency
and openness issues if you want to do
such a large event so we're hoping to be
able to connect with the office of
research and have this larger scale
event in the future I think it would be
a great way to help people at all
different levels of research acknowledge
the impact and you know again the animal
lives that were used
so really after putting this
presentation together I sat back and
realized that
I think the take-home point is that you
have a hugely diverse staff a lot of
them are in very different places in
their careers as I mentioned we have
technicians that have been with us for
15 years we have technicians oh that was
us for six months you have you know vet
tech resident in again your office staff
or your cage wash you don't deal with
the animals on the daily basis so having
this wide range of plans set up to help
address compassion fatigue can really
make it a much more beneficial program
to everyone you know because what works
for one person might not work for
everyone and I really enjoy having the
animal enrichment committee be so
involved in improving our overall
community
and our program as we've developed it
has been a little bit of trial and error
I will admit as well there's a little
bit of well what's the harm and
basically having a more positive work
environment regardless of what you're
trying to address and then we've been
working to pinpoint improvements we can
make so we do track staff participation
and get numbers for each events that we
have we try to make sure that the items
were creating are useful and that the
animals enjoy them and we've been asking
for staff feedback and anonymous service
try to see what types of services they
would like to see more of and to see how
they felt about the services that we
have so far
the next step global domination I wish
but we do have a greater vision so right
now our program supports the unit for
laboratory animal medicine which is
primarily as the husbandry technicians
and vet staff that support our overall
research community so we've talked about
wanting to set it up to where anyone
involved in research have these same
resources
uhit hurdles there we have hundreds of
PI's so each of those investigators then
obviously has their own lab staff which
can range a number so just quickly end
up with thousands of people who are on
animal protocols and each of those
laboratories has their own culture so
some researchers you're still going to
hit that wall of not necessarily
understanding the nuance of compassion
fatigue so you might have start over
with the education process but we hope
in the future we can expand and make
sure that every single person who's on
an animal protocol and in some might
benefit from some of our ways that we
use to combat compassion fatigue
every enrichment presentation that I've
given oftentimes to our outreach
programs to students of all ages I
always end with better welfare equals
better science so as we move forward to
improve the care and welfare of our
animals we get better results so with
working now more with people and trying
to combat compassion see I would argue
that if you improve the welfare of your
staff it also improves the welfare of
your animals and you still end up the
set that our science
I would like to say a special thank you
to Kaylie Bennett and Marian assault who
were the first ones to recognize this
need for a department-wide response to
compassion fatigue they reached out
initially to the U of M counselors and
has still been very active in improving
our program and they really kept the
ball rolling dr. Jenny Lofgren who is
the faculty advisor for the animal
enrichment committee as well as the real
lab and Sarah Thurston who is my current
co-conspirator in ongoing efforts to
combat compassion fatigue
thank you
and thank you so much Jennifer for that
informative presentation and your
important research we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now audience members just
click on that ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click that send button once there's
many times questions as we have time for
so let's take a look at our incoming
questions from our audience members
Jennifer the first question coming in is
how do people get involved
well we try to offer as many
opportunities as possible and we require
no commitment
so people are welcome to drop in on any
activity or project that interest them
it is all voluntary and you cannot refer
someone and go I think so and so really
have some compassion fatigue issues they
have to come to us we work really hard
to vary the times and locations because
as I mentioned we have a large campus so
we try to make it as easily as possible
and also we have an email list as well
as a Facebook group Explorer welcome to
join as I another way to get information
from us
thank you our next question is is it
necessary to have trained counselors
available
I always say absolutely yes and
essentially a lot of these issues are
mental health issues and with anything
like that you can end up with some
serious concerns that are best handled
by professionals and we've also found
that by reaching out to them ahead of
time we can make sure that we've set up
a supportive environment which we feel
better referring our employees to than
say a therapist or counselor that might
not be comfortable with what we do
thank you and again thank you for the
incoming questions from our audience
members just want to remind them that
any questions not asked today will be
answered via email we have one with time
for one more question Jennifer here's
the last one
where does the funding come from well
the short answer is we don't have any
but the support for our employee time so
for people attending events the meeting
comes from management and then a lot of
the events that you see are sponsored by
the animal enrichment committee we
actually roll the expenditures for those
under the cost Center for each species
as we will eventually be using those
items for enrichment we design those
projects with minimal cost but right now
we have no overall programs support or
official funds that are just for the
compassion fatigue group thank you for
that and Jennifer do you want to provide
the audience members with any closing
remarks before we close our our webinar
today nope just feel free to email more
questions I'm happy to answer
wonderful thing
so much before we go I do wanna once
again thank you for your presentation
and I'd also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye
you
all righty